standout tv
i hope i stand out with you you know do
you remember my name yesterday
i'm just gonna leave oh
that's not even her name
hi i'm sean reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views that you know i'm saying
it's all good right now charm aren't ya
and i've had some bad dates how do you
think you're done on the date i don't
really give a sh i'm not gonna lie about
it where are all the decent men not in
my dms that's for sure you get me i feel
like i'm rolling with the man then
what's going on baby fives it seems like
a lot of men don't know how to treat a
lady i'll just man handle everything and
this guy's putting a chest and chest in
the nut like geez
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling my name's notes and um i'm
here to date a beautiful woman
i might get a bit hot in the grilling
only because i've seen a couple
grillings before and i'm not really
trying to get grilled
slyly because she's actually very very
nice you know i mean i don't really do
dates
nah just you know have fun
right about i feel like i'm in love
island right
do i want a relationship um i mean if
she does everything that ticks all the
boxes then why not what do i expect from
a girl on the first date just be you man
be baby you know i mean don't be too
stuck up but don't be too free up let's
get it you know what i mean let's get it
on
why hello
hello how are you doing you're alright i
gotta eat this oh that's really nice
quick how are you doing you're good let
me give you a little hug
ah he actually just bought me a gift
like that's really cute that's really
thoughtful you know i thought we might
as well do the date properly ah see i
like this with um
some style bit of bubbly so what's your
name um
cool did you do this to all the women
you don't um no i don't you lying to me
oh you lying no just seeing her for the
first time ever is just like
you know life changing for me um
i really hope that she can take me
seriously and you know just believe that
i'm not some
way you look amazing by the way before
you carry on there's a charmer isn't it
are you good at opening champagne oh
yeah of course are you what's in here do
you want me to open it now oh yeah oh
god there's some chocolates that i like
in there so yeah are you like oh so
would you buy them for you no i'm just
saying we could share together and
what's mine is yours what's yours is
mine you're a trophy oh
let's move it
this guy's got game i can't lie
oh this is really cute
very nice gotta make sure
it doesn't bob a lot oh really i'm not a
big drinker so i don't know any
techniques i think she's loving this you
know i'm not even gonna laugh i think
she's loving this right now is he trying
to get me drunk so how many glasses um
of champagne do you pour for women
um
it's barely any are you sure you look
like you're really good at this um me
and the man them like to celebrate
you sure because you can't make eye
contact if you say that oh no i'm just
making sure i don't spill the champagne
anywhere but um me and the mandom like
to celebrate okay would you like to
celebrate clubs
studio
depends on what we're celebrating okay
tell me a bit about you so i like to
make music i've been doing that ever
since i could talk
i like helping people make music as well
so how do you move as a as a man to
woman how do i move to women
i don't know
i don't know i'm just myself do you not
get women then i'd like to think i do
but i might not i don't know
these questions are a bit majin art i
didn't expect this
he's definitely a playboy how many women
have you slept with oh that number can
run for
time what do you mean come on for time
you know what i'm a virgin i want to
lose my virginity i would love to lose
my virginity too up to 100 or 100 plus
it's a sticky one still so are you a
ladies man no i'm just chilled man
yeah i'm sure so on average how many
women do you sleep with in a week oh my
god this guy slept with everyone in
london you know what recently i've
actually chilled the [ __ ] out and it's
mainly been like
one person so if i'm chatting to one
person i'll be
in that one person for as long as would
you say you're good in bed glad to
believe so i've been told that i am
what's your technique in the bedroom a
lot that's a lot
i like to carry
yeah so i'll pick you up exactly
so i don't know if i'm strong i just
like harriet no
all right she needs to kind of
ease off with trying to get into my
business too much or not enough about me
though why haven't you found a man yet
why are we even on this stage you know
what it is i'm just trying to i've had a
few dates in it yeah i've had a few yes
oh what's going on a lot of people are
talkers and it's like not many people's
actions are congruent with their what do
you know because it's like you can say
you're a really good man and you do all
this and tickle these boxes but so would
you say you're a really good woman
absolutely what boxes do you feel all of
them it's not your fault
what boxes it's not even about boxes
ticking it's because for me i've spent
the last few years like doing i'm big on
personal development so i spent years on
myself and making sure that i am a good
woman okay you know and what does it
take to be a good woman i think just
kind caring compassionate and selfless
being a good woman in the home with love
and with those around you and stuff like
a hub so you feel like you can take care
of a home yeah absolutely i think that's
standard but can you cook yeah i can
cook can you yeah very good cook very
great yeah my mandom would have like say
hi things about my cooking really girls
would too um if they've been that close
so how many women do you cook for um i
think i've only cooked for like
four how many people have you actually
slept with huh
i told you i'm a virgin no you're not
how many people you set with i want to
lose my virginity to you how many people
have you stuck with
take my virginity please if you start
off on honesty
you get a lot more
yeah the numbers a lot okay just say in
between i don't even know i couldn't
tell you so it's over 100. it's probably
have you ever like had sex with a fan
yeah
really yeah why would you do that i
don't know
i'm always a bit young okay
so you'd never go back there no no
no no no no nice you've learnt from that
yeah i've learned from her what did you
learn from my many mistakes so how many
fans have you slept with there no no i'm
just saying many mistakes in general it
doesn't have to always be about sleeping
with someone yeah
yeah i'd love to know what your body car
is though i don't answer that question
why
and usually i don't even ask girls this
is very interesting you've been really
really on to me why are you lying so
what if i slept with a hundred man a
hundred men
no man not for me not for me
then that's on you that's what you want
to do that's the amount of souls that
you want to be tied to that's on you but
then would that change the way you value
me as a woman no no no you could still
be part of the clerk yeah but there's a
difference being part of the clique and
then being your woman are two different
things men and women are two different
things
so he's a playboy and he's sexist
you are very different you have periods
we don't we just have blueballs yes then
why is it mad for us to then be as
liberated as you are i'm not saying that
it's it's mad i'm just saying there's
there's a difference between men and
women you lot feel more than we do
emotionally you know
have much more feelings than we do and
i'm not condoning
my behavior or no men's behavior of this
whole uh yeah i can
i can sleep as much girls as possible
i'm not condoning that however i would
never condone a woman
just
freeing it up to everyone by all means
you can do what you want to do but you
can never be my wife does that make
sense so we can be friends we can be mad
cool i'll never judge you i'm not i
don't [ __ ] watch i don't judge people
where
but you couldn't be my wife yeah but why
i don't like for me it's because you
made your choice you made your choice
you made your bed so lie in it you can't
have that energy for yourself and
different for me you've got a hundred
people going inside your guts
yeah and you've gone in a hundred
peoples yeah but exactly you see the
difference i've gone in
you understand that it's still energy
exchange in your situation they'll be
going into you so i was like your guts
have just been muddled up over 100 times
but my will still say the same
no
it doesn't work like that
if you're 25 and you slept with 100
people that's a bit of a concern as it
goes but what if you're single what if
you've been single like your whole adult
life that's a lot
that's a lot of man how long have you
been single for a few years what's a few
years a few
what's a few years like three
maybe four hours you've been racking up
the numbers no
365. no 365 days in a year no
times how much
three years you said
that's roughly around a thousand
something days so where are you going
with this a thousand something days
divided by ten yeah you've probably been
with around 100 plus
365 days
times free
nah surely she's on her bits
she must be
where are you from
around here
what's around here essex
interesting why is that interesting well
huge your rava joey six or notes
nights
oh you're the best the god bless cheers
thank you babe
i saw that
now i'm moving up to him
it's cute do you like being famous
it does get a bit drying because i don't
have my own personal space you know i
mean like
i don't have my own
privacy i don't have my own every single
time i wake up i have to be nuts
you know i mean when i go to sleep i
have to be naughty you don't have to no
you do man i can't go outside and just
be angry
and then a fan comes up to me one in the
picture and i'm just vexing that [ __ ]
off that i can't do that but if i was
who i am or the person before notes or
whatever the case is like somebody's
trying to snap me i'll tell them about
what the [ __ ] you doing that you know
i'm saying that yeah but now it's like i
don't know i can't even get a wine in
the corner you know what i'm saying i
can't even dance in the corner and chill
with a girl because somebody's trying to
snap me how is that for you that's dead
but it is what it is i'll just i'll just
tell him delete it right i'll get one of
my mandom to scare him to delete them
how does this affect your mental health
i always feel like i'm being watched it
feels like the truman show have you ever
watched youtube
yeah i love that film as well but that's
what it actually feels like generally
like i always feel like i'm being
watched she's got me chatting bear in it
it might be the drink though i can't lie
ah he's actually opening up dude for
saying i've tried it
but i don't really enjoy it why i don't
know it's not it's not really my thing i
might just head out do you when you've
ever done it once like
i've done it like maybe twice or three
times just to confirm what you've only
done it three times in your whole life
yeah
even in your serious relationship yeah
man like d-block europe was screaming
about it so i thought you know what let
me try it you know what i'm saying like
let me give it a try give it a taste
didn't taste nice nah man didn't really
go my way
drink your pineapple should be right no
no no if you're gonna do it you need to
be confident yeah because i feel like if
you're just like a bit i'm timid yeah
i'm so shy really
oh that's a shame
do you suck
cheers
why are we choosing i'll say cheers
all right you know silence
that speaks a thousand words she didn't
even need to say anything i can see it
in her mind i know she gives that mad up
i could just tell
when did you last have sex maybe like
four or five days ago do you have sex
just often
not like i rate someone so
i'll be seeing them for however long
that is how long is that so how
importantly do you spend with someone
before you move on to the next person it
depends man it depends what kind of
connection we have it depends what kind
of history we might have if we don't
have any history at all
it depends what kind of person you are
whether i feel comfortable enough to be
chilling with you and have you check in
to the palace you know
i feel like you're the type of person
that would like give boyfriend vibes
and then the moment someone go a woman's
like what are we you're just like just
friends i feel like you give me that
vibe
that you'd kind of lead someone on into
thinking it's going somewhere ah this is
long
this guy is not serious
naturally i am a loving person you know
i grew up
with my mum mainly you know i'm saying
she had me at a super young age 17. i've
just been
caring towards women so if i have a
woman in my presence and she's actually
chilling with me for quite a while
whatever the case is i'm naturally gonna
show love towards her that doesn't mean
that i'm in love with her though
i'm sure you are loving after sleeping
with 5000 people
yeah you're dangerous it's just the
truth how is that dangerous how can i
show you love for two weeks and you
think i'm in love with you and you want
to move and get married and have kids no
but that's what i'm saying you're doing
so listen no i'm not i'm just being a
man i'll take you out i'll make you feel
good whenever we do we'll go to a club
if you want something
in a club that's not selling dreams
that's hanging with someone that's yeah
but just being able to like if we're
doing all that and you're giving me all
this energy
if we're doing all that yeah and then
out of nowhere within a few weeks you're
just like oh by the way we're just
friends can you not see where the issue
is i wouldn't i wouldn't say that unless
you're giving me signs that you want to
take this further than i do do you have
commitment issues then yeah do you yeah
i feel so that's central to you so how
how do you deal with that
i don't know mom i just continue to be
me and now she keeps talking about
commitment and she's like she's central
safe she needs to relax sweaty it's none
of her business none of her issues no so
you're not going to take any
accountability for your behavior or your
actions
um cheers
no i'm not choosing until you answer it
cheers cheers to being what
out
[Applause]
well here i am trying my best to you
know do the best and she's out i just
disrespect me like what
me
you know blood
do you think people
go with you for your lifestyle instead
of you
sometimes i think that
which is right which is potentially like
what could be part of the commitment
issues
i didn't know you from before i was me
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry so it's like
why do you want me so does that play
into how you view women slowly but i
still vibe i still have a good time and
if you can show me past that then by all
means we get past that but then if you
can't show me past that then you'll end
up staying
where you know wherever i stop so how
does a woman show you that just being
genuine just being genuine no man just
being real getting your own ubers when
you know when you want to come see me
just little tiny stuff like that means a
lot like oh yeah you want to see me all
right cool so you figure out something
to do for us to see each other or
whatever oh let's go cinema i bought us
two tickets that will make me think
for our like even if the tickets cost 20
pound or whatever the case is is that
for us she fully took her time out to go
and plan some for us and bought two
tickets for us we're going for dinner
yeah and i wanted to split the bill on
first date would you split the bill
first i wouldn't split the bill but i'll
be
so happy that you've wanted to split the
bill like inside me i don't know
i can go on a couple more dates with you
have you ever taken a go on tour
no but i'll take you on tour like stop
trying to sweet talk me i'll take you on
so i'm being serious why do you think
i'm joking i like your vibe i like your
aura what can i say
i like the energy that i get off of you
really i think i'm a bit cold no i don't
feel that i feel like you're a bit warm
i might have to leave you know i'm not
gonna lie
she doesn't even believe a word that i
say anyways you're selling a lifestyle
and you're selling the dream to me so
realistically how are you actually gonna
find a good woman if you're doing it not
necessarily though i'll be able to sense
all like pre-certain mannerisms of that
person
for example yourself
um if i have you around me and showing
you this lifestyle whatever the case is
you could try and act as though you're a
genuine person but you can only keep
that act up for
a certain amount of time a limited time
what's a red flag for you um dead
toenails did you like fate
my feet are not great but i love a woman
with great feet so would you have a foot
fetish i don't know if there's a fetish
i just love great feet did you put my
foot in your mouth it depends what kind
of scenario and what did you watch
lesbian sometimes lesbian
i like two girls what did you have three
sims then yeah how many phrases have you
had
that it happens quite a lot
is it your idea or like
sometimes i'm just shocked how noble of
you just to help a woman out if that's
what they want you know you've got to
give women what they want
he thinks he's so smooth
so how do you deal with like grief as a
man i don't know like being able to just
confronting people as well as is
it's important
i feel like laughing
and smiling is super important as well
because i laugh and smile a lot but i
only do that because there's a lot that
i've been through or a lot that the
people around me have been through and
the best way to kind of deal with that
is just to laugh about it but crying is
important though no it really is man it
really is rest in peace jamal edwards as
well he passed away recently
so i'm sad but yeah like it's it's crazy
to see it happen even fresh eagle kid
mark marvin morgan
it's mad but the best thing we can do is
be there for them in whatever way and
carry on fulfilling their legacies and
[ __ ] yeah i like that absolutely what do
you influence in your music
i just like to spread love spread
happiness spread joy like letting people
know that yeah like you're bigger than
whatever
you think you are
what's your favorite track of yours
just me or or collaboration however you
want to take the question probably love
of my life um with young ads
a bigger remedy on the on the buttons
but yeah that's probably my favorite
because it has different meanings to it
and it was because me and him were
standing in the booth and it was one mac
and we're just
moving leave each other away when we're
ready to spit it was mad natural so i
felt old school you know i mean and
because you're the love of my life also
yeah now i think she's the one
maybe the two would have got a three
or four
or five so how do you shoot your show up
excuse me miss
you come with that yeah you're right
what have i said now i'm having a bad
day i want to make that day a bit better
where are you heading to right now time
hey then home how about we go grab some
ice cream
that's quite cute
or hot chocolate if it is cold you know
i mean have me to talk to you know i'm
saying you can come finding me what's
going on in your day what's up and then
are you expecting sex on that day no no
no of course not i wouldn't even expect
that to be a date i'm just you know i've
just met you i'm talking to you i'm
trying to make sure that you're okay
because you told me you're having a bad
day
ah that's an attentive
um
yeah i don't think it's that deep man
say for someone that wasn't in like your
world or your industry did you not see
is it being like really bad
no
if i had a girl with you or my girl
let's put it like that when am i going
that's where that you were lacking
pictures
of
celebrity people like let's say storms
you were still on the ground and you're
liking storms these pictures
i don't know i wouldn't automatically
start saying
storms you get out my house
yeah it's a bit mad didn't it collect
things in it it's like deep yeah it's
just like but then at the same time if
you're consistently lacking somebody's
pictures it could raise a concern you
know what i'm saying but if you're
genuinely into that person's music into
what they do yeah like a fan yeah you're
a fan of their there for the community
whatever the case is and i can realize
that all right cool now you actually
genuinely like that person
there's nothing i can do about that yeah
i've got friends that might have
boyfriends
and i'm saying so what they shouldn't
like my picture just because they have a
man and their man's about it no man grow
up grow up here
yeah i'd see you again
my heart oh my god
i actually thought that was her no oh
yeah no that's amazing you want to see
me again i'd love to see you again what
do you mean by seeing me again i'm
physically on
tv i'm not talking about youtube i'm
talking about like real life okay where
are we going um where do you want to go
in london now could you just take
everyone on tonight i've never taken
anyone i don't know had them take me to
london i i really like fall but
if you've taken me somewhere you've
taken another woman it'll make me so mad
i won't take you to
phuket
thailand i won't take you to
portugal algarve i won't take you to
milan or rome do you just take women
places and just that's it no why are you
not making eye contact i'm just i'm just
reminiscing but i won't take you to them
places
but everywhere else i'll take you oh
barcelona maybe not so this can't go
anywhere no everyone else everywhere
else i could take you i feel like this
is i feel like what you do with your
lifestyle you just take women places and
it doesn't mean anything
i don't know you did just have a long
list just then no but the list could
have been with people that i've taken to
multiple places so it could be one
person that i've taken to multiple
places
maybe exactly
i can't believe she's actually believing
hey but it is what it is though man
yeah would you yeah i'm friends with
quite a few of my exes also yeah is that
friends so you don't increase your body
cut no listen i've never slept with an
ex i after i've done done with them i've
never gone back there ever
yeah look at me that's very good if
you're an ex i will then value you as a
friend but i'm a good woman
and i will put 100 into us so if we
don't work that's on you i've had good
women told me they're good women and
they're not good women yeah but i know
i'm a good woman that's what about sure
yeah because the fact that i can even
hold a relationship with my exes like
i'm very chill and that's why my exes
respect me and they stay in my life
friends with your ex i feel your ex is
your ex for a reason
kmt really so if i was with you yeah as
arms going for dinner with my ex why
would you go for dinner with your ex
but you can't go for dinner with me i'm
hungry i'm going to review i don't get
why you'd want to link your ex because
we're friends
like what if we're actually friends
why am i even here
so what if i had done that how would you
feel
yeah i'm i'm very secure but i think
also it depends on your behavior yeah
because absolutely if you make me feel
secure as a woman i'm not going to have
to question why you're meeting your ex
and i just posted with her and it's just
chilling but if it depends there's rules
to it like if you're if you're not
posting me it's people now i'm your
woman and then you'll start posting next
i will be like what are you doing okay
cool that's one room what other rules
are there
wow she keeps talking about rules and
that what was she talking about that who
made these rules like are you the law
like what is this
because this is intriguing i'm
interested i don't understand
how you can just you know go for dinner
with your ex it's because i'm an adult
so that means you can go for dinner with
your ex yeah because i can have a
breakup that's not toxic okay so someone
that was blowing your back out you can
be going to go and visit them for dinner
yeah because it was years ago i'll
respect it but it's just and it's just
youtube yeah we can easily do that and
just hang out why are you not looking at
me
this this is i'm
confused like the people that i've dated
are good men so it's nice to know
they're with good women if they are no i
hear all of that
but nah
that's dead it's not dead no that's dead
you know what
what do you think this is
just chill
come and chill with me
i'm your man no one else is your man but
to me i'm your man i am the man you
chill with me you don't chill anywhere
else this is not antarctica it's not
chill
no understand no that's a bit scary
storm that's a red flag i'd much rap
bites okay so but would you not rather
maybe
chill with an ex and on good terms and
have a crazy psycho exercise i'd love
for you to be chill with your ex and be
on good terms but that doesn't mean that
you should be going to dinner and lunch
and coffee with that particular person
and just that person
beauty play man said booty booty plate
what is this son no one's touching my
bum
[Laughter]
yeah or no what's the beaut what spooky
take it any way you want with the
question as in like a beauty call
touching me oh yeah i can touch your
beauty but no one could touch my beauty
what's your card then no but i'm not i
need to
we need to clarify this before i pick up
oh you could pick it up and explain your
answer so would you want to touch beauty
i'm selfish i just like
mind being touched oh you like yours
being tired okay yeah if we're talking
about yeah touching your beat yeah i
love i'd love to mine is off limits oh
how long have you been doing music what
do you mean professionally
about seven six years so at what point
did you have that transition where it
was like oh my god like i'm gonna make
it as an artist well addison lee is when
i felt like ralak i'm being noticed as
an artist
and then like aladdin was when i felt
like all right cool now people are
taking me seriously because they thought
addison lee was just a one-hit wonder
thing
but then i've come through with aladdin
and then sit back down and my lover was
like ah cool yeah i've built a strong
solid foundation
and there's no way that i can be removed
as an artist in the uk especially but
then at the same time i really don't
feel like i've
made it yet
because i feel like i've got my own kind
of goals and [ __ ] so like what people
might view as made it to me it's not
neither you know i mean that so what's
your goals
i'm trying to take over the world yeah
yeah man i'm trying to do
stuff that has never been done before do
you love an ambitious man
you look amazing by the way i just
wanted to say again okay is that the
drink talking now um nah it's me talking
and the drink only brings out the truth
in people any song is what it is thank
you your eyes are
stunning thank you oh he's smooth with
it he's got bars you know
what would you do if my ex was after you
i'll ask you to send me money my enemies
are after me
would you not fight for me but why is he
after me because he wants me to go i'm
not familiar but you're not and i'll see
you guys
time for girl and fight if you're a
woman a different
i'll say go take her really he's your ex
for a reason right so you're only going
to decline him so then he gets declined
by you and what's he gonna do fight me
again i'll just say go take her go have
her
just give me up so easily yeah i'll say
it's for you
and then you're gonna reject him and
then it's just not gonna happen but now
i've lost you as well if you wanna lose
me that's cool yeah because you just
feel like i'll have her
yeah but that's because he wants to
fight me for you
even though he doesn't have you that's a
bit he's moving mad yeah he's moving a
bit dumb if it was a different situation
where he was just after me because he's
after me and something happened and very
very cool that's different
i'll tempt him like but would you say
you're a fighter
i knocked someone out the other day why
no i don't like guys that fight
um he was chatting mad
and he's being disrespectful so i was
not tamar but i'm a lover like there's a
lover i'm a lover as well i'm a lover of
it i'm a lover as well how's your day
we're holding hands now
what would you do if i wanted to start
an only fence you still hold my hand
yeah yeah yeah hold your hand um it
depends if you're just showing your
hands on only fans then by all means
on your feet then cool my girl with only
fans am i dead
what she should be my only fan
really so what's your thoughts on women
in the adult industry
nothing wrong with that man i respect
their craft i respect what they do oh
about as your woman doing it though
i don't respect the craft i don't
respect what they do
respects it until it's your woman not a
hundred but then oh the candle's gone
out they just blacked out you're lit so
it's cool
no he's funny you know what izzie i just
feel like
once again with the body count thing or
whatever the case is like i can't have
my woman going out like that if she's
mine you're not meant to be shared if
you're mine you know someone i'm saying
am i attracting you
it
i love it
it's coming off
all right trust me i stand out tv
i hope i stand out with you you know do
you remember my name yeah shanae
i'm just gonna leave oh
that's not even her name
who is sinead
one of his other women
fam i can't believe i've said one of my
things named
instead of her name do you know how dumb
that is
not shanae
wow wait hold on properly
there's bad girls in my head right now
so how many women are you talking to i'm
actually not talking too many so why
many others
i'm just talking to one currently and if
you're better than that one then by all
means
what would you do if i got put in prison
for five years would you wait for me
yeah would you yeah i'll just stick to
my gran would you really not entertain
other women no entertainment probably
just get head
if
five years i have to bus or not there's
no way
that i ain't slamming
while you're in that slammer
you can just have
um i don't use my hands
really she's holding it up
no no no no you don't touch me i'm not
saying there's anything wrong with how
do you release yourself
those are women
you said that i did
the whole masturbating thing i just feel
like a waste man afterwards what what do
you mean you just brush your knot like
in your hand and you're just looking at
your head you're thinking [ __ ] like what
did i just do
do you think you can be with one woman
um no i could i think i could think i
don't know because i'm not in that
position yet i don't have one woman to
stick to do you want just one woman love
to raise a beautiful family with just
one woman um i have many kids with that
just one woman i have like a massive
christmas tree and it's christmas
you know i'm saying mother's day me and
the kids will get her something i would
love to do all of that what would you do
if i was in a gang
what are you talking about proper gang
yeah i'll tell you to go get a job
really yeah
go get a good job don't make money i am
making money no you're not in my gang
what by doing whatever selling you're
selling drugs and even the drugs that
you're selling you're selling it for
somebody you are selling it for somebody
so it's like
oh you're not making money i know how
how much food you make in a day you're
not making money so what did you do then
no i'll just tell you to grow the pot
she's all talking about gangs what's
wrong with her like being in a gang
ain't cool fam there's not there's
nothing cool from it you don't even make
bread from it like what are you doing
you got me here just there like haunted
for the rest of your life dead that man
some essex gang
you crazy yeah well pushing that that's
what i mean that was not porn oh well
essex and that you know what i mean
what's your type by the way my type
you you can't say that like why she's
your type i'm saying you
a girl that likes to wear hoops and that
is
brown ass
then pretty brown has like keane or some
um she knows how to dress
quiet tips for nails on the toes are you
trying to be a child nose as well i
thought you just talked about women so
i'm not even filming for you i'm being
serious i'm not talk
do you think you're telling me
we've almost finished a bottle of
champagne so i guess so um
that's not out of board and that's just
sort of
flowing natural beautiful conversation
so um maybe but when are we going on our
second date when you ask me
can we go on the second day please yeah
but you gotta actually ask me and pursue
it i'm asking you know i'll book it
right now in front of you
all right cool well you can book it yeah
you just just don't i like when the
manager's alpha don't ask me because
nothing will get done just book it tell
me a time and a place and just that's it
as well do you want to like be on the
boat
that's too cold for them
i did enjoy my day
i love my date i'm not even gonna lie to
you yeah there's a bit of bad no you
know i mean that yeah some of the times
i wasn't really
being serious and i was saying but
overall isn't a phenomenal date i've
never been on a date like that before no
done really well it's either that or the
champagne talking
yeah no i think i was all right on that
barbecue grill you know i mean i don't
think that there was a problem um i
didn't sweat i'm still wearing a bomber
on top of
my t-shirt so yeah man i think i handled
it quite well are you actually going to
go to london either then yeah
he booked it
yeah no i have to take her london there
now i've made the promise and i've done
it on camera don't really grill him did
i he was strategic there bring in the
champagne
i think i'll give myself a solid
man
oh he's quite confident his name
he definitely rates himself quite high
probably about eight actually no man i
put probably in a [ __ ] heart-shaped
box but i'll give myself a 15 man so he
dressed nice
brought me a gift
he was quite smooth and he also booked a
second date whilst we're there that's
the alpha energy we want so i'm going to
give him a 9.1
[Music]
[Music]
you